Os lo hemos contado en un pasado vídeo, Rusia
lleva años intentando reducir su dependencia
de las economías occidentales. Lo ha hecho
reduciendo la financiación exterior, acumulando
enormes reservas e impulsando una política
de sustitución de importaciones.
Sin embargo, el resultado no ha sido particularmente
bueno. La economía rusa sigue dependiendo
mucho de los suministros extranjeros. Particularmente
en lo que respecta a la alta tecnología.
Por eso ahora las sanciones internacionales
que los aliados han impuesto sobre Rusia están
comenzando a castigar duramente la economía
de este país.
C1(“Las mejores estimaciones que estoy viendo
salir ahora mismo sugieren que la economía
rusa va a recortarse a la mitad de lo que
era antes de esta invasión”. Daleep Singh,
Asesor Adjunto de Seguridad Nacional de los
Estados Unidos)
Para que os hagáis una idea en 2021, cerca
del 80% de los fabricantes rusos afirmaban
que simple y llanamente no podían encontrar
en Rusia todos los componentes que necesitaban
para su actividad. Este es el caso del fabricante
de camiones Kamaz que acaba de reconocer una
caída de la producción del 40% por falta
de componentes. Según ha reconocido la empresa
hay 15.000 empleos en riesgo.
Además, según un estudio de la Escuela Superior
de Economía de Moscú las importaciones supusieron
en 2020 casi el 75% de todas las ventas de
bienes de consumo no alimentarios.
Pero ahora las sanciones están cerrando los
mercados internacionales a Rusia. Lo que puede
suponer un golpe muy duro para su ya maltrecha
economía. Esto es algo que ha reconocido
el propio Vladimir Putin.
C2(“Nuestra economía necesitará profundos
cambios estructurales en estas nuevas realidades,
y no ocultaré esto, no serán fáciles".
Vladimir Putin, Presidente de Rusia)
Ya os podéis hacer una idea de lo que todo
esto supone en realidad si el propio Putin
habla de dificultades en un país donde las
cosas oficialmente siempre salen bien.
Pues bien, justo aquí es donde todas las
miradas se han puesto sobre China. ¿Rescatará
el gigante asiático a la economía rusa?
¿Hasta qué punto puede contar Moscú con
el apoyo de Pekín?
Pues… Queridos amigos, amigas en este vídeo
vamos a ver todos los detalles.
Atentos.
[Pero, un momento, porque antes de seguir,
quiero hacer un apunte importante. Este vídeo
ha sido posible gracias a Masterworks.
ESTANFLACIÓN: Seguro que no dejáis de oír
esta palabra.
Un peligroso cocktail entre inflación alta,
desempleo y bajo crecimiento económico
En España nos estamos acercando mucho a tasas
de inflación de dos dígitos, solo en marzo
llegamos al 9,8%. Estados Unidos tampoco se
queda muy lejos.
¿Y cómo podemos proteger nuestros ahorros
ante esta imparable estanflación? Bueno pues
no hay una respuesta sencilla ni única, pero
la diversificación siempre parece de las
opciones más sensatas en cuanto a protección.
Y como apuntaban recientemente desde J. P.
Morgan, en este proceso de diversificación
los activos alternativos han venido para quedarse.
Y, ¿qué mejor ejemplo de activo alternativo
que el mercado del arte? Aquí es donde entra
Masterworks. Masterworks permite a personas
de cualquier parte del mundo
acceder a un mercado hasta ahora inaccesible
para el común de los mortales: el arte.
El proceso funciona así:
El equipo de análisis de Masterworks estudia
miles de datos para encontrar obras financieramente
atractivas con potencial de revalorización.
Luego, las compran por importes que van desde
el millón de dólares hasta los 30 millones
y las titularizan mandando una oferta pública
a través de la SEC.
Por último, conservan la obra entre 3 y 10
años hasta que se vende.
¿Pero es rentable el arte contemporáneo?
Bueno, pues este mercado consiguió mejores
datos que el propio SP 500 incluyendo dividendos.
Apreciándose un nada desdeñable 164% en
los últimos años, de 1995 a 2021.
Ojo, muy importante: nadie puede predecir
el futuro, y resultados pasados no aseguran
rendimientos futuros.
Si quieres echarle un vistazo a Masterworks
por ti mismo, te dejamos un link con el que
te puedes saltar la lista de espera.
Y, como siempre a la hora de invertir: mucho
cuidado, no existe nada libre de riesgos.]
Pero dicho esto, ahora sí, arranquemos. ¿Hasta
dónde llegará la ayuda de China?
1(IDILIO EN ORIENTE)
No es un secreto. Durante los últimos años
la Rusia de Vladimir Putin y la China de Xi
Jinping han fortalecido mucho su relación,
tanto en el terreno político como si hablamos
del propio ‘business’.
El gigante asiático es con diferencia el
mayor socio comercial de Rusia. De hecho casi
una cuarta parte de todo lo que compra Rusia,
desde ropa hasta televisores, procede de la
República Popular China.
(Y no solo se trata de intercambios comerciales.
Rusia también se ha convertido en uno de
los principales receptores internacionales
de préstamos de instituciones financieras
chinas. Concretamente, entre los años 2000
y 2017 el oso ruso recibió financiación
china por más de 150 mil millones de dólares.
Una cooperación que también alcanza el campo
militar. Tal y como os ya contamos en el boletín
de Patreon, ahora los dos países realizan
frecuentemente maniobras conjuntas.)
Quizás por todo esto, cuándo los dos líderes
coincidieron en Pekín el pasado 4 de febrero
del 2022, con ocasión de los juegos olímpicos
de invierno, declararon que la amistad entre
ambas potencias no tenía límites. Una amistad
sin límites.
De hecho durante ese encuentro, apenas unas
pocas semanas antes de que Rusia lanzara su
tormenta de fuego sobre Ucrania, se firmaron
varios acuerdos:
Por ejemplo, China levantó las restricciones
a la importación de trigo ruso y los dos
países acordaron incrementar sus intercambios
energéticos. Es decir, que durante los próximos
30 años China comprará más gas y más petróleo
ruso.
Precisamente por este creciente idilio entre
Pekín y Moscú, cuando los aliados comenzaron
a castigar la economía rusa con sanciones,
todas las miradas se volvieron de repente
hacía China.
Un país cuyo gobierno ha rechazado tajantemente
el uso de sanciones económicas contra Rusia.
C3(Desde 2011, Estados Unidos ha impuesto
más de 100 sanciones a Rusia Sin embargo,
¿han resuelto algún problema las sanciones
de EE. UU.? ¿Es el mundo un lugar mejor gracias
a esas sanciones? ¿Se resolverá la cuestión
de Ucrania gracias a las sanciones de Estados
Unidos a Rusia? ¿Se garantizará acaso mejor
la seguridad europea gracias a las sanciones
de Estados Unidos?" Hua Chunying, portavoz
del Ministerio de Asuntos Exteriores de la
República Popular China).
La pregunta es, ¿Acudirá China al rescate
de Rusia? ¿Puede China mitigar el impacto
de las sanciones en la economía rusa?
¿Se plantearán las empresas chinas lanzarse
a por los activos y los mercados que están
siendo abandonados por las empresas occidentales?
Y ojo, porque ya se especula con que algunas
empresas como la China National Petroleum
Corporation, la China Petrochemical Corporation
o la China Minmetals Corporation, tres gigantes
públicos, se están planteando comprar ya
a precio de saldo muchos activos rusos.
Pero, ¿realmente puede China salvar la economía
rusa?
Pues… lo cierto es que no está tan claro
que puedan ni quieran.
Atentos.
2(CUESTIÓN DE CAPACIDAD)
La primera pregunta que tenemos que hacernos
es…. Exactamente, ¿Qué podría hacer China
para apoyar la economía rusa?
Pues veamos, podemos poner sobre la mesa varias
ideas:
Por ejemplo, el gobierno chino podría facilitar
las transacciones comerciales, reduciendo
aranceles y trabas burocráticas.
Podría suministrarles componentes que ahora
Rusia ya no puede comprar en Occidente.
O podría también hacer que sus grandes empresas
públicas invirtieran en compañías o proyectos
en Rusia.
O adelantar el pago de parte de los 140 mil
millones de dólares que el banco central
ruso tiene en deuda del propio gobierno chino.
Incluso podrían crear un banco títere para
ayudar a Rusia a saltarse algunas de las sanciones.
China podría hacer todas estas cosas… Pero
el problema es que nada de esto sería suficiente.
(Por un lado, Rusia tiene una economía pequeña
y poco desarrollada que básicamente exporta
materias primas. Así que por mucho que los
chinos estuvieran dispuestos a comprar cosas
en Rusia, lo cierto es que no hay mucho margen.
Además, Rusia sigue vendiendo sus materias
primas a Occidente, pero incluso si eso cambiara,
por ejemplo, por un embargo petrolero, para
vendérselas a China, se necesitarían unas
infraestructuras que hoy por hoy no existen
y que tardarían años en construirse.)
Sí, sí, las cosas no son tan sencillas como
un simple cambio de cromos.
Por ejemplo, en 2021 China importó de Rusia
10 mil millones de metros cúbicos de gas
desde Rusia a través del nuevo gasoducto
de Siberia. ¿Sabéis cuánto exportó a Europa
ese mismo año? 175 mil millones de metros
cúbicos.
Y eso por no recordar que en Pekín tampoco
van a estar dispuestos a depender excesivamente
de Moscú.
Luego por su parte las empresas chinas tampoco
pueden compensar la pérdida de acceso a productos
avanzados que ahora las sanciones prohíben
vender a Rusia.
Y no pueden por tres motivos:
1) primero porque aunque muchas cosas se produzcan
en China, eso no quiere decir que se puedan
vender a Rusia. Los productos que fabrican
las empresas occidentales en China no pueden
venderse a Rusia.
2) Segundo, porque tecnológicamente las empresas
locales chinas o no están tan avanzadas o
dependen de suministros de empresas occidentales.
Suministros que podían peligrar para ellos
mismos si luego los productos terminan en
Rusia.
(Ahí tenemos por ejemplo el caso de los aviones.
Las sanciones internacionales prohíben a
las empresas occidentales como Airbus o Boeing
vender aviones, componentes, piezas, motores
o servicios de ningún tipo a Rusia. Cosas
que por supuesto hacen falta para que los
aviones sigan volando. Y China o no las fabrica
o ya ha dicho que no se las van a vender.)
3) Y tercero, porque muchas empresas chinas
tienen miedo al riesgo reputacional que las
pueda terminar perjudicando en mercados mucho
más lucrativos y también a que se terminen
aprobando sanciones secundarias, es decir
sanciones a Rusia y a las empresas que trabajen
con este país.
Esto es lo que ha hecho que empresas como
Volvo o TikTok, que son de propiedad china,
hayan suspendido algunas operaciones en Rusia
que no estaban afectadas por las sanciones.
Y exactamente los mismos motivos explican
por qué dos de los "Cuatro Grandes" bancos
estatales de China, el Banco de China y el
Banco Industrial y Comercial de China, limitaron
sus operaciones con Rusia en cuanto comenzó
la invasión. Que es también lo mismo que
ha hecho el Banco Asiático de Inversión
en Infraestructuras, por así decirlo el banco
mundial chino, que ha suspendido los préstamos
a Rusia y a Bielorrusia.
C4(“China está tratando de mantener a Rusia
a distancia. No quieren exponerse eludiendo
las sanciones internacionales". Simon Harvey,
jefe de análisis de divisas de Monex Europe)
En esta misma línea, respecto a la inversión
en Rusia, sí, es posible que algunas empresas
públicas chinas terminen comprando en Rusia
activos a precio de saldo, pero no parece
muy probable.
El miedo a las sanciones, al riesgo reputacional
y el hecho de que el mercado ruso es muy pequeño
son cosas que frenan cualquier desembarco
masivo.
Por ejemplo, pensemos en Xiaomi que tiene
casi el 40% del mercado de smartphones de
Rusia. Sí, seguramente se beneficiará de
la salida de empresas como Apple, pero difícilmente
asumirá el riesgo de realizar grandes inversiones
en un país que apenas representa el 3% de
sus ventas globales.
C5(“China no salvará el barco que se hunde
de la economía rusa. Quizás permitirá que
flote un poco más y se hunda un poco más
lentamente”. Eswar Prasad, economista de
la Universidad de Cornell)
Es decir que incluso aunque el gobierno de
Xi Jinping quisiera realmente echarle una
mano a Rusia es posible que no tenga la capacidad
de hacerlo a gran escala, [porque por supuesto
los chinos no quieren perder por el camino.]
Pero es que lo cierto es que ni siquiera está
claro que realmente quieran salvar a Rusia.
Atentos.
3(POR FAVOR, NO MÁS PROBLEMAS)
La economía china no atraviesa su mejor momento.
En 2022 espera crecer un 5,5%, su objetivo
más bajo desde 1991. Y desde luego no está
nada claro que lo vayan a conseguir.
China está actualmente lidiando con una crisis
inmobiliaria, una posible crisis financiera,
con las secuelas de la intervención del estado
en el sector tecnológico, con la competencia
de nuevos mercados de producción como Vietnam,
con un Congreso que tiene que reelegir a Xi
Jinping, con una crisis demográfica y para
colmo, con el dichoso coronavirus.
Porque sí, en China siguen encerrando a la
gente en sus casas.
N1(Aumenta la presión en Shanghái, una ciudad
de 25 millones, mientras los cierres por covid-19
siguen vigentes. CNN)
¡De locos!
Es decir, que China no está precisamente
para tirar cohetes.
Suficientes quebraderos de cabeza tiene ya
el gobierno de Xi Jinping como para arriesgarse
ahora a sanciones y problemas de todo tipo
por apoyar a una economía tan pequeña como
la rusa.
Fijaos por ejemplo en este gráfico:
Mientras los capitales están entrando en
la mayor parte de las economías emergentes,
están saliendo de China - lo que puede agravar
la crisis de este país. Es posible que la
invasión rusa de Ucrania haya cambiado la
percepción de muchos inversores y que ya
no se fíen tanto de China.
Una salida de capitales que puede verse agravada
por la subida de tipos de la Reserva Federal
norteamericana, ¿por qué? Porque cuando
un país como Estados Unidos sube los tipos,
al reducirse la brecha de rentabilidad con
las economías emergentes los inversores prefieren
invertir, por ejemplo, en deuda de Estados
Unidos que en deudas de países con más riesgo.
Lo que puede hacer peligrar una buena parte
de estas inversiones
Y eso no es todo. Para colmo la guerra de
Ucrania ha contribuido a incrementar el precio
de la energía, las materias primas y los
alimentos. Otra castaña más para China.
Una economía, amigos, que ahora necesita
más que nunca la inversión extranjera y
los mercados internacionales para sus exportaciones.
¿Y sabéis qué? Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea son mucho, muchísimo más importantes
para China que la economía rusa.
¿No me creéis? Pues solo tenéis que echar
un vistazo a los números:
(En 2021, el comercio entre China y Rusia
fue de unos 147 mil millones de dólares.
Con Estados Unidos la cifra superó los 825
mil millones y con la Unión Europea los 750
mil millones.
Es decir, el comercio con Estados Unidos y
la Unión Europea fue en 2021 casi 11 veces
mayor que el comercio con Rusia. Y todo esto
por no hablar de países aliados como Japón,
Corea del Sur o Australia que casi seguro
cumplirían con cualquier sanción internacional.)
Eso sobre el comercio. Sobre los flujos de
inversión la cosa es aún más exagerada.
Así que, resumiendo: China tiene problemas,
China necesita los mercados y a los inversores
internacionales y Rusia en la economía mundial
importa más bien poco.
Y aún no hemos terminado.
4(UN INCENDIO O UNA OPORTUNIDAD)
Queridos amigos, amigas, para China la invasión
rusa de Ucrania se está convirtiendo poco
a poco en una enorme puñeta.
Los costes de la energía se han disparado;
el miedo de los inversores ha crecido; la
guerra está frenando las rutas ferroviarias
que conectan China con Europa vía Rusia;
y para colmo ahora los vecinos de China están
anunciando incrementos récords de su presupuesto
militar. Lo que por supuesto no hace ninguna
gracia en Pekín.
Shinzo Abe, el exprimer ministro de Japón
se ha mostrado incluso partidario de llegar
a un acuerdo para que Estados Unidos despliegue
armas nucleares en el país del sol naciente.
Así que podríamos decir que, cada día que
pasa, la invasión de Ucrania hace menos gracia
en China.
Sin embargo, un momento, porque para Pekín
podría tener algo bueno. Fijaos.
N3(Xi Jinping instó a Joe Biden a trabajar
en conjunto por la paz: "La guerra no beneficia
a nadie" France 24)
Sí, ahora China puede negociar con Estados
Unidos su “neutralidad” a cambio de ciertos
beneficios. Por ejemplo eliminar parte de
los aranceles aprobados por Trump.
De hecho, al poco de producirse la invasión
rusa, el 18 de marzo del 2022, Xi Jinping
y Joe Biden mantuvieron una cumbre telefónica
que mejoró el tono de las conversaciones.
Y como gesto de buena voluntad, la Administración
de Biden acaba de eliminar los aranceles sobre
352 productos chinos y las empresas chinas
cotizadas en Estados Unidos se dispararon
en bolsa ante la esperanza de que las relaciones
entre ambos países se normalicen.
Así que sí, es posible que las empresas
chinas compren activos a precio de saldo en
Rusia. E incluso que el gobierno de Xi Jinping
haga algún gesto de cara a la galería, pero
difícilmente las cosas irán mucho más allá.
Lo más probable es que China ni siquiera
intente rescatar a la economía rusa.
Mala suerte para Moscú.
Ahora bien, ¿Cómo está Rusia preparándose
para hacer frente a las sanciones? ¿Cómo
espera resistir el gobierno de Vladirmir Putin
al castigo que los países aliados le están
imponiendo a Rusia?
Pues eso, queridos amigos y amigas lo veremos
en un próximo vídeo aquí en VisualPoltiik.
Así que no no olvides suscribirte al canal
si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Y por supuesto si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante echanos una mano dándole a like
y dejando tus impresiones en los comentarios.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.